welcome to this video amateur at blitz
yeah what can you do that sir probably
right from Sweden and we have the bull
goin on the board why I Catalan water
but it's not a big game big difference
when you play a 5 it will usually
transpose they are knowledge it has
transposed castles e5 is the main line
of this of this line now I'm their
various moves Bishop g5 for example
there should be three bishops you one
even let's see what is going for I'm
head on the clock mark it on your
calendars 40 seconds now ok I'm going to
take on d to this is of course one idea
of the whole openings with swapping the
dark squared bishop and then putting
pawns on dark square so that you have a
healthy structure here maybeee form ok
now is preventing that but in the
process putting yet another pawn on
earth on a light square I'm hoping to
exploit that
yeah look see one no OS must be cautious
95 and stuff but ok this is simply not
the position for that but still always
need to be alert when you put the Queen
opposite the the rook ok should I play a
for him yeah maybe I should have maybe
done it a bit earlier hmm yeah my light
squared Bishop is really a bit silly
this piece ok yeah man maybe I should
have done that one move earlier and then
go Queen a five maybe Knight b6
something like that this hmm was may be
preferable
hmm so what is this I have a healthy
structure that's nice but I also don't
have any space it's not so nice what is
this about equal maybe hmm well if Y
term is going to get anywhere in this
game he needs to some are open the
position like specify if for example
which is not it it was not possible here
but something like that what's always
bad is the capture on e5 I mean this is
almost almost bad because it helps me
enormously giving you the c5 square so
d5 would be a big here this is also also
tricky let's say unless there is a
tactic unless there is a tactic with 95
I mean
yeah it can take you for this is what I
was thinking can take a form eat for not
a 494 tween 85 rook a five hmm maybe we
can hear some light night move I but
wait wait wait wait wait just a moment
just a moment if I take on d to first
Queen d2 I can take on f6 was check as
well okay come on I need to do this
anyway at least it seems i need to do it
the question is does he have any great
discovered moves with the knight on f3
knight c 7 is not maybe rock d 8 and I'd
be five something like that but also be
on I'm at the moment temporarily not
very well coordinated I just need one
move like this one maybe it's as
possible whoops if I a night c5 just
covering the night only form hmm wow I
don't know it looks like I'm very email
not coordinated here if he attacks it I
can go where g5 okay let's not let's not
even spent more time night edge Freud
this is also a bit strange I mean the
nidus you know it helped to attack here
before but other than that on edge for
its doing nothing maybe I can go to d5
yeah
if i go to f6 now well that's not so bad
actually maybe this is in fact an option
letting him take and take on these six
to play Bishop e6 coordinate my pieces
yeah but still 97 rook da droga5 Vlaar
up at age 3 is hanging okay
maybe I was calculating one move to 220
here night see some lube the a droopy
5983 the I am hmm ok night h3 check may
I ask a drug the six at the end of all
this ok maybe I need to plan look f8
then this is very hairy what the heck
maybe hmm yeah I am yeah I know I know I
know what do I do now look these six
heavens hmm
shoot night h3 King King where our King
age 21 group t6 even taking work 2-6
[ __ ] okay come on let's put this back
it's a it's still playable I guess I
hope now the rook is hanging for once
it's saying it's hanging and I can take
it I didn't see that like resins wow wow
Roy you really put up some some fight
here with rookie fire and stuff I have
the hunch that the computer is going to
suggest some some big improvements here
from both sides okay yeah nice d2f 690 d
to f6 mmm this I didn't consider night
deep six looks like a very logical move
check yeah this is just good this is
just good to the text see form I
probably will win it and this is an
offside piece yeah very good suggestion
by the comp here yeah it gives Knight f6
is equal and this is probably too risky
I don't know Rukia fate oh yeah and this
is probably not good and now g6 I must I
must play I think this is this is not
possible I thought this one I have 94
hmm but even this isn't this isn't this
very very tricky I can go here but wow
it looks it looks like don't know
very threatening ok I went here and now
fortunately he just blundered the rook
he needs to take and then I hmm the
compounds to take with the pawn I would
have taken with the bishop instantly
this bed might a fiver strong ok yeah
come on 95 I didn't didn't see that idea
but I can take right add then Rock 26
Wow ok hmm now ok that's not a very
human way to play all night at five
maybe maybe but now look 26 and after
that it's it's not so and why this
better of course it's a better better
multiples perform yeah it's a bit lucky
all that this means that here I'm I did
something wrong I need to do I need to
improve him the thing is that this is a
strategically problematic move if the
pawn structure gets frozen like night be
success for instance an interesting try
if it takes I can
hmm now this I don't think don't know
here not clear the cell they could have
taken here but I thought that ah yeah
this is what I need to do yeah this is
what I need to do this is a solution I
need to take exactly i need to take and
that was what I didn't really appreciate
is Queen d5 and now i can take rook
takes and Knight b6 or Knight f6 and I
regained the pawn with the temple yeah
this is very important something like
that gym now okay look up here is a
problem I cannot go f6 do 295 00 p1m
yeah complicated stuff okay thanks for
watching